this family begins its routine at dawn
and their buffaloes always start the day
along with them and this popular Marsh
in southeastern Iraq the Khalil family's
income depends on the animals they sell
yogurt and buffalo milk but demand has
dropped and so have prices coronavirus
restrictions means fewer visitors to the
area
the virus is really hurting us and our
sales and milk prices almost collapse
now we can't even go get hay to feed the
animals we've had to start selling our
animals to buy Tomatoes meat and other
things when longtime clients like Sadiq
Muhammad do make the trip they buy less
a combination of curfews and job losses
are slowing down sales in nearby
provinces and whatever is insult is
thrown away we buy milk from the Buffalo
breeders in the marshes but when we try
to sell it nowadays no one buys it so
now we're only buying a small quantity
before the outbreak 30 litres of milk
would sell for about 28 dollars now they
get 12 with little income many herders
see no other option but to sell their
buffaloes they have no other jobs to
turn to selling animals they've raised
and care for appears to be their only
option despite some pushback if my
father wants to keep selling the
Buffaloes I'll be very sad he knows how
much I love them I hope he forgets about
selling them the marshes were declared a
UNESCO World Heritage Site in 2016 they
were drained by Saddam Hussein in the
1990s to punish and force out rebels
over the years so wetlands and the
community recovered but now the corona
virus poses a different type of threat
katya la posada Yan al-jazeera